hallo ich hab hier so'n scheiß pickel
also beachteten einfach nicht sondern
konzentriert euch auf mich ich wollte
mich dafür entschuldigen dass in letzter
zeit so unregelmäßig videos kam und dann
auch videos mit dem ich selbst nicht so
ganz zufrieden war und ich war da auch
ehrlich gesagt nicht so gut gelaunt ich
war halt zweieinhalb wochen komplett weg
ich war im urlaub und danach waren die
video dates und gamescom und noch andere
produktionen und dann musste ich einfach
sehr viel vor produzieren und wenn ich
ganz ganz viele videos mache dann nehme
ich mir tatsächlich wirklich den spaß
ein bisschen daran dazu muss ich auch
derzeit sehr viel lernen weil ich in
zwei wochen fünf klausuren schreibe und
nebenbei habe ich immer noch uni und das
steigt mir alles ein bisschen zum kopf
dazu bin ich auch noch total krank von
dem video days weil mich irgendwie keine
ahnung wenn man täglich mehrere leute
umarmt dann ist es einmal nicht
ausgeschlossen dass man so ein paar
bakterien abbekommt und einfach krank
wie ich habe mir jetzt allerdings wieder
im zeitplan gemacht mit videos und alles
mögliche dass ich das alles schaffe und
hoffe einfach dass die videos in
nächster zeit besser werden bzw
ich weiß gar nicht wie man eigentlich
hat keiner gesagt dass die videos in der
zeit kacke waren aber ich fand sie
selber einfache ich bin war ich war da
nicht so ganz zufrieden mit ich
vielleicht bin ich da zu
perfektionistisch aber ich fand es
irgendwie ich gut dafür wollte ich mich
einfach entschuldigen und ich war
gestern hat den ganzen tag noch bei
seiner produktion mit europa und danach
habe ich wollte eigentlich ein video
aufnehmen aber dann habe ich mir diese
ganzen sachen angeschaut die ihr mir was
ich zeige euch das mal eben was ihr mir
ja alles geschenkt habt also
beispielsweise eine ananas hier mützen
hier bionade flaschen in höheren spiele
wo solche karten alles klar luca
hörspiele und einfach unglaublich viele
briefe hier ist wirklich alles voll mit
brief uhr
jetzt mache ich ja auch noch wieder
alles kaputt ihr kissen riesige plakate
ist einfach mega krass sogar so selbst
gestrickte mützen damit war ich halt in
letzter zeit sondern so ein bisschen
beschäftigt mir das alles wirklich
durchzulesen und voll viele haben halt
wirklich in briefen gefordert hey luca
ich habe zu hause noch sachen für dich
aber die konnte ich nicht wie das mit
nehmer die so groß sind macht doch mal
ein postfach und alles mögliche deswegen
ich weiß nicht ob ihr bock auf sowas hat
aber viel
ich welche massen postfach einrichten
oder auch nicht würdet ihr also ich weiß
nicht ich krieg das du bist mit wie viel
das einfach ist das ist einfach so viel
aber um wieder auf den willen des videos
zurückzukommen ich wollte mich
entschuldigen und ich wollte sagen dass
die videos der nächster zeit besser
werden ich habe mega coole sachen
geplant wieder coole spiele rausgesucht
auch teilweise spiele die schon so als
ich aber unbedingt noch mal zocken
wollte und dann würde ich sagen sehen
wir uns jetzt gleich noch in einem
weiteren video wieder weil ich heute
zwei hochladen also gleich noch ein
gaming video von einem coolen iphone app
oder halt in den nächsten video sei
macht gut schuss